-So everybody is talking about
the reboot of "Roseanne."
The first few episodes
got huge ratings,
and it really
seems to have connected
with a large group of people.
So now here to talk about it,
please welcome two fans
of the show "Roseanne."
-Hey, Seth!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks for having us, Seth.
-We are so excited to talk about
our favorite show, "Roseanne."
-So tell us all,
what is it that you guys love
about "Roseanne" so much?
-Well, it's simple.
The networks finally made a show
for people like us.
-Okay, great. Now, so when
you say "people like us,"
obviously, you mean
Trump supporters?
-God, no!
We're talking about people
who love the sexy,
soulful saxophone journey
that is the "Roseanne"
theme song.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
The theme song?
-Yeah, you know,
the one that goes...
-♪♪ Ba-da ba-da, ba-da, ba-dow ♪♪
♪♪ Ba-da-da, da-dow ♪♪
♪♪ Bow-dow, ba-da ba,
ba-ba-ba bow ♪♪
-[ Imitating harmonica playing ]
-I'm -- I'm just
gonna cut you off,
'cause we all know
the theme song.
It's great.
But I guess my question is,
what did you think when you
actually watch the show?
-Well, we don't watch the show.
We watch the theme song,
and then, we turn it off.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's too bad,
'cause I was hoping
we could talk about the show.
You know, because a lot of
people are upset
because they feel as though
the show is giving a platform
to Roseanne,
who is a Trump supporter
and a conspiracy theorist.
-Yeah, but a lot of people
like the show because...
♪♪ Ba-da ba-da, ba-da, ba-dow ♪♪
♪♪ Ba-da-ba, bew-bow ♪♪
♪♪ Ba-dow, ba-ga ga,
ga-ga-ga bow ♪♪
-[ Imitating harmonica playing ]
-Yeah, but I guess --
I think the thing is,
"Roseanne" has peddled some
pretty dangerous falsehoods,
not to mention the fact
that the show's success
probably means
we're about to see a lot more
sympathetic portrayals
of Trump supporters on TV.
And even the President himself
has called Roseanne
to congratulate her
on the success of the show.
-♪♪ Ba-ba, ba-ba-ba-ba,
ba-ba, ba-ba-ba bow ♪♪
-[ Imitating harmonica playing ]
-Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two "Roseanne" fans, everybody.